joe biden's also feeling the heat at
home over his pandemic recovery plans
for the economy
now several u.s states are looking to
slash emergency benefits in a bid to
boost their job markets
restaurants across the country have been
struggling to hire enough staff despite
hiking pay rates to attract applicants
critics claim generous unemployment
checks leaving many people reluctant to
search for work although
that argument's been rejected by the
white house
how does the white house know that
people are just choosing not to
apply for jobs because the extra
unemployment benefits are so good
we don't see much evidence that the
extra unemployment
insurance is a major driver in people
not
rejoining the workforce amid
kovid restrictions being eased and more
people vaccinated the us saw
266 thousand people find new jobs in
april
but that was still way off the mark of
what economists predicted they expected
around a million to find work
the shortfall meant there was little
improvement in the overall unemployment
rate
through until the autumn americans are
receiving an additional payment of 300
per week which is sometimes higher than
what's being offered by employers
child care issues schools being closed
and no vaccination yet are also said to
be discouraging people from going back
to work
but president biden insists america's
economy is headed in the right direction
and the low job figures therefore
justify his new spending plans
we put the issue of how the u.s
government should move to a
post-pandemic economy
up for debate when you
have not working
paying almost as much if not more than
working that creates a disincentive for
people to go
and get jobs in the economy and that was
on purpose during covid we didn't want
everybody flooding in after you had
disruptions
in hospitality and travel but we need to
be thoughtful about how we move
out of that coveted economy and back
into a more normal economy
and i think wages are going to have to
rise in order for that to
move forward properly the schools have
not really opened in the u.s in most of
the places they say they're open but for
maybe a couple hours
or a couple days a week well that means
parents have to continue teaching their
kids
they can't go back to work i suspect
that a lot of the recall to work
businesses are just testing the market
and bringing people back at part time
in other words their weekly earnings are
far
less if you want these people to come
back uh
raise the minimum wage for these people
pay them
a decent wages so they can afford child
care
make sure they have the same hours of
work that you did before and
the people will come back to work the
idea that all these benefits
isn't having an impact on the
unemployment numbers is absurd
sure there are other aspects of this
that there are other factors in this
equation
but yes they do need to start moving
more towards getting people back to work
which means not paying them to stay home
and we need to reopen our schools that
is a that is a factor
as well that is a good point so it's not
so this won't fix the problem
as far as just removing the benefits but
we also need to reopen schools
there's also the fact that there are a
lot of people especially here in austin
texas who are just afraid to go back to
work
one because they're getting the benefits
and because they're still afraid about
coven so it's a variety of factors
but we we can't say that that the
benefits have nothing to do with this